من الفضاء وليالي الارض التي تتزين بانوار
النجوم البعيده وهذه الصوره الراسخه في
خيال كل انسان قد تكون مهذبه دراسه جديده
وجدت ان نسبه سطوع الضوء الاصطناعي من
الارض تزداد بنسبه 10% كل سنه ما يعني ان
عددا كبيرا من النجوم التي نراها ستختفي
العلماء حذروا وعلى سبيل المثال ان الطفل
المولوده تحت 200 و50 نجما مرئيا على سبيل
المثال لن يتمكن من رؤيه 150 منها ويتبقى
له 100 فقط من هذه النجوم بحلول عيد
ميلاده الثامن عشر
طبعا المشكله هي تلوث الضوئي الناتجه عن
الاضاءه الاصطناعيه للارض اذا التلوث
الضوئي يحجب النجوم ولذلك تاثير كبير على
الحياه على الارض
القصه جميله وحزينه ومعقده نتابع المزيد
عالميس
اذا نظرت الى السماء ليلا فقد ترعى عددا
كبيرا من النجوم او قد لا ترى نجوما على
الاطلاق والسبب التلوث الضوئي ففي المدن
والمناطق التي كثافه السكانيه العاليه من
المستحيل تقريبا رؤيه النجوم تمتد دوره
حياه النجم الى مليارات السنين وقاعده
عامه كل ما زاد حجم النجم كلما كان عمره
اكثر تتعلق بعد النجوم اكثر من غيرها وسبب
سطوعها هو مقدار الطاقه التي تطلقها وماده
بعدها عن الارض كما يمكن ان يختلف اللون
من نجمه الى اخرى لان درجات الحراره ليست
كلها متشابهه فعاده تظهر النجوم الساخنه
باللون الابيض او الازرق بينما تظهر
النجوم الاكثر بروده بالام برتقالي او
احمر
عندما تحدق في نجوم المتلالئه في سماء
الليل فانك في الواقع ترى ماضيها بين انها
قد تكون ماتت بالفعل فقياس المسافات بين
النجوم خارج نظامنا الشمسيه يكون بالسنوات
الضوئيه وغالبا فانك تنظر اليها كما كانت
من قبل من المستحيل للبشر معرفه عدد
النجوم الموجوده في الكون لكن يقدر علماء
الفلكان فيما جره الدرب التبانه وحدها
يوجد حوالي 300 مليار ناس
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا من الشركه عمار عبد الله مساعد
في مرصد الشارقه البصري وينضم الينا
تحديدا من مرصد الفضاء اهلا بك معنا يا
عمار صباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدك معانا
مباشره من مرصد الفضاء
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير للمشاهدين ولكم ايضا
عمار
تصبح اكثر سطوعا 10% كل سنه ما يعني ان
كثير من النجوم التي نراها قد تختفي هل
بالفعل تم توثيق هذه التغيرات في سطور
السماء من قبل المرصد
نعم شوفي احنا عندنا مشاكل كثيره تواجهنا
بخصوص الرصد الفلكي واحده منها تلوث
الضوئي يعني هذا احنا بنبغي نرصد نوع من
انواع النجوم بشكل معين
نحتاج ان احنا نسوي دراسه عبر برامج معينه
عشان نشوف النجم هذا هل يكون مرئي ولا لا
هذا بغض النظر عن اللي هو التلوث الضوئي
نشوف السيزنبل
مساحه السماء اللي احنا نشوفها على اختلاف
الفصول واختلاف الموقع الجغراف
مش نفس النجوم بنشوفها في امريكا
بص عمار خلف
ما
هو التوب
الدرجه اكثر من الجمله تتاثر بهذا الشيء
النظم النجوم خافضه طبعا التلوث الضوئي هو
الاضواء المدينه اضواء الشوارع اضواء
البنايات الاضواء المختلفه هي تتسبب في
التشتت الضوء اللي احنا بنستقبلها من
النجم بحجه انه التلسكوب همم
يرصد جميع الاضواء اللي يقدر عليها اي
اضواء من المدينه اي اضواء من السيارات
هذه الاشياء تدخل في العمليه الراسيه
وتسبب في انخفاض ثقه العمليات الرصديه
احنا نحاول ان احنا نروح اماكن بعيده في
الصحراء الصحراء الرزين على سبيل المثال
وادي مدينه همم نحن نتجنب هذه التلوثات
الضوئيه وكل ما يزيد التداوي احنا هذه
المساحات الصغيره لان المدن تدخل في هذه
المساحات
هل تتوقع ان يكون تلوث الضوئي اكثر سطوعا
من هذه النجوم وما حجم او عدد النجوم التي
ستكون اكثر سطوعا من التلوث الطويل
يعني احنا هني بشكل مخصوص في منطقه
الشارقه من مرصد الشارقه البصري نقدر
الحمد لله حاليا نحن نشوف النجوم الساطعه
مثل نجم سيريس نجم سهيل لكن نجوم خافته
نواجه صعوبه نحن نرصدها واحنا عندنا تحليل
الضوئي باستخدام الطياف الفلكي عندنا هذا
المطياف موجود هنا نحاول ان احنا نرصد
اطياف النجوم ناخذ الضوء من النجم غير صدق
الطيف ان شتت الضوء وناخذ اللي هي
الفيتشرز
اللي في الالتموسفير في الغلاف الجوي
للنجم هذا النجوم خافتها ما نقدر نسوي لها
هذا الشيء لان اكثر النجوم متعدده اللي هي
الثنائيه وانا متعدده والمتغير تكون
النجوم خافته
عمار النجوم تختفي عنوان مخيف جدا
ومتصدر كل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وصفحات
الاخبار اليوم ماذا يعني ذلك هل لنا ان
نتخيل فعلا السماء بدون نجوم وايضا الليل
بدون نجوم
[موسيقى]
على هذا النسق مبين الموضوع مخيف جدا
للعامه وخصوصا ان احنا بدنا نحنا كعاصدين
فلكيين راح يكون عندنا لميتيشن لراسه
الفلكي نحن قد ما نقدر نحاول نتجنب هذا
التلوث الضوئي قد ما نقدر ونطلع جبال مثلا
على اساس ان احنا نصغر العمود العمود
الضغط اللي موجوده في الغلاف الجوي
والتاثير عليها لان احنا مش التلوث الضوي
هو المشكله الوحيده اللي عندنا لكنها من
اكبر المشاكل فاحنا يعني نحاول ان احنا
نتشاكل
[موسيقى]
لان احنا ننسلب جماليه
الاجرام السماويه المختلفه
همم وعمار ايضا نشير ونذكر بان النجوم
قديما كان ينظر اليها الرحاله ويتابعها
المرشدون حتى يستدلوا على المواسم سواء
مواسم زراعيه ايضا مواسم الطقس وكل هذه
الامور المرتبطه والسفر ايضا بالتالي هل
سيختفي المرشد التقليدي باختفاء النجوم
[موسيقى]
القديمه كان ينظرون الى السماء وكانت اصلا
تنير الارض عليهم من كثر ما هي النجوم
مبينه النجوم الساطع مبينه حتى النجوم
الخائفه مبينه وداخله في سطوع اللي هو
الليل حتى في همم في الايام اللي مسبقه
لكن حاليا بتطور والتكنولوجيا اعتقد انه
راح يصير نفس النظر عن همم الطرق
التقليديه في تحديد همم نفسه عندي ذكرتي
الفصول همم الملاحه الجويه الطقس فرح
للاسف انا راح يصير غض النظر عن هذا هذا
وجه من او وجه ال همم التطور اللي انا
اشوفها بصراحه لان هذه همم الطرق
التقليديه نفسنا يعني طبيعيه همم سهله
دائما متواجده بس التكنولوجيا لازم واي
فاي لازم همم برنامج الى اخره شكرا
عمار عبد الله مساعد في مرصد الطريقه شكرا
جزيلا لك